R
EXPERTISE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT UPDATE.
NOW LET'S TURN TO ANOTHER
FESTERING BIDEN CRISIS, THE
CRISIS THAT IS OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER, AN UNMITIGATED MESS.
TWO STRAIGHT MONTHS, THE U.S.
SET RECORDS FOR ILLEGAL BORDER
CROSSINGS.
THE WORST NUMBERS IN OVER TWO
DECADES.
ACCORDING TO NANCY PELOSI,
BORDERS ARE KAMALA HARRIS, HAS
IT COMPLETELY UNDER
CONTROL.
LET'S SEE, SHE SAID SHE WAS NOT
BRIEFED ON IT, SHE HAS NOT BEEN
TO THE BORDER.
I DON'T QUITE SEE WHAT NANCY IS
SEEING BUT UNLIKE
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS, OUR OWN
SARA CARTER NOW HAS BEEN DOWN TO
THE BORDER NUMEROUS TIMES, UP
CLOSE AND PERSONAL, BRINGING US
DIFFERENT INVESTIGATIVE REPORTS
REGULARLY.
SHE JOINS US NOW WITH THE LATEST
INVESTIGATIVE REPORT.
IN TEXAS TONIGHT, SARA CARTER.
>> SEAN, JUST TO GIVE YOU AN
IDEA OF WHAT HAS BEEN HAPPENING
HERE, JUST TODAY, THE MEXICAN
MILITARY, MEXICAN MARINE CORPS
UNITS WERE ACTUALLY ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE RIVER, ACTUALLY
APPREHENDING WHAT THEY CALL
COYOTES, OR SMUGGLERS ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
THERE WERE FAMILIES ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE RIVER THAT WERE
FRIGHTENED AND AFRAID, AND THIS
IS AN AREA, HERE IN DEL RIO,
TEXAS, WHERE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
CROSSING BY THE HUNDREDS, BY THE
HUNDREDS, DAILY, AND ESPECIALLY
THIS WEEK, SO IT'S INTERESTING
TO SEE THAT CRACKDOWN, BUT THE
DEMOCRAT MAYOR OF A DEL RIO,
TEXAS, HAS A STRONG MESSAGE FOR
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
HIS DEMOCRAT COLLEAGUE.
I WANT YOU TO HEAR WHAT HE HAS
TO SAY.
>> THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
TELLING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
TAXPAYING CITIZENS, THAT IT IS
UNDER CONTROL.
HOW IS AN INCREASE OF 396% UNDER
CONTROL AND THIS TIME LAST YEAR
IT WAS -- WE ARE AT 97,000 IN
THIS ALONE.
>> DOES IT UPSET YOU IN THE
MAJORITY OF MEDIA IS NOT
COVERING --
>> THERE IS NO ACCOUNTABILITY,
NO DETERRENCE, NO -- NOT EVEN A
SLAP ON THE WRIST.
YOU CAPTURE ANY RELEASE.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
>> AND THEY ARE SENDING THAT
MESSAGE HOME.
>> I WAS ELECTED TO DO A DUTY
AND PROTECT MY COMMUNITY, AND WE
NEED A PURPOSE IN THE SAME
PARTY, THEN SO BE IT.
I'M NOT GOING TO BACK DOWN.
>> SEAN, YOU CAN HEAR THE
FRUSTRATION IN THIS DEMOCRAT
MAYOR'S VOICE.
HE REALLY WANTS THE
ADMINISTRATION TO LISTEN.
RIGHT NOW, I AM HERE AT HARRIS
RANCH.
I SPOKE TODAY TO A RANCHER,
JOHN, WHO SAID THAT HIS
FRUSTRATION IS SPILLING OVER,
LIKE EVERYONE ELSE HERE IN THE
COUNTY, THEY FEEL LIKE THEY ARE
NOT BEING HEARD.
THEY FEEL LIKE THE PRESIDENT IS
NOT PAYING ATTENTION, THE
VICE PRESIDENT HAS NOT BEEN HERE
AND IS NOT LISTENING TO THEM,
AND THEY WANT THE REST OF
AMERICA TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY
ARE ACTUALLY GOING THROUGH,
LISTEN TO THE FRUSTRATION IN
JOHN'S VOICE AS THEY DESCRIBE
WHAT THEY ARE GOING THROUGH
EVERY SINGLE DAY HERE IN HIS
COUNTY AND ON HIS RANCH.
>> I WANT YOU TO DESCRIBE TO ME
WHAT HAS BEEN HAPPENING OVER THE
PAST THREE MONTHS.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I WOULD JUST
SAY, IT'S AN UNPRECEDENTED
MIGRATION.
I'VE NEVER SEEN IT THIS BAD,
I'VE LIVED HERE 25 YEARS.
WHAT I DON'T WANT IS ALL THE
PROBLEMS.
YOU KNOW, WE ARE HEARING STORIES
OF GUNS AND HEARING THE STORIES
OF CONFRONTATIONS.
WE ARE GETTING CONFRONTATIONAL.
THE PEOPLE ARE GETTING
CONFRONTATIONAL WITH US.
THAT IS NOT THE NORM.
>> ARE YOU AFRAID YOU MIGHT LOSE
YOUR WAY OF LIFE HERE?
>> OH, FOR SURE.
YEAH, FOR SURE.
WE HAVE ALREADY LOST OUR WAY OF
LIFE.
YOU KNOW, EVERY DAY HAVING TO
BATTLE THIS, GO TO BED AT NIGHT
AND KNOW THAT THERE'S TWO, FOUR,
SIX, OR EIGHT OF 'EM COMING UP
YOUR FENCE, POTENTIALLY COMING
TO YOUR HOUSE.
>> SEAN, I SPOKE TO SO MANY
FAMILIES OUT HERE, FAMILIES THAT
ARE TERRIFIED.
THEY SAY, LOOK, THEY'VE ALWAYS
HAD PEOPLE MIGRATING ACROSS THE
BORDER, BUT IT'S NEVER BEEN LIKE
THIS.
THEY HAVE LITERALLY MEANT
SHOWING UP AT THEIR DOOR.
THEY WANT TO PROTECT THEIR
CHILDREN.
MANY OF THE RANCHERS OUT HERE
FEEL ALONE, BUT THE MOST
IMPORTANT MESSAGE THAT THEY HAVE
FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN AND FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE IS GET A PLA